curiosity has been often referred to as
closing a knowledge gap and this goes
back to Berlin's work goes back to a lot
of work being done by Lichtman and his
colleagues presently who distinguish
between two forms of curiosity interest
epistemic curiosity and knowledge gap
curiosity that privation they call it
the reason that they call it that
privation is because there is has been
an argument that if you are curious
there is a certain kind of negative
feeling that you experience before your
curiosity is satisfied and once you have
this answer you feel a relief and a
positive feeling comes over you we argue
that if you are interested and you are
searching for more information that is a
rewarding experience and you do not
necessarily or you are unlikely to have
an aversive feeling except you can have
negative feelings developed because you
have a problem in your search but that's
different than trying to close a
knowledge gap the way that I can best
demonstrate you how we consider
curiosity and interest to be different
is by telling you to think about when
you read a detective story when you read
a detective story the minute you find
out that who actually is the murderer
you might not even want to finish your
book and compare that to reading like
say Harry Potter or some really
well-constructed book that you're not
simply trying to find out a knowledge
gap you are interested in many of the
characters you are interested in the
ideas you are interested in the
relationships and you will keep on
reading that book not only is the
lengths of time different and the
aversion different but they're also the
purpose is it's different like when you
are interested you are searching for a
lot of information not just a specific
information to close the knowledge gap
now there are some
answered issues about this for example
what happens if you have interest in a
content but there is a knowledge gap
that you're closing is that now
different from just being curious and we
argue that it is because for example
take a bridge expert who loves playing
bridge he is reading a book with many
many puzzles ok solving bridge hands he
goes and solves a knowledge gap and then
continues going on to other questions
other puzzles because he has that
individual interest in the content that
propels him to go on for further
activity